Comment allez-vous nous sommes avec Mamytwink et François
-Salut -
Florian à eu une idée géniale il m'a dit" mais mec qui serait drôle qu'on fasse une vidéo où on essaie de survivre
une nuit en pleine forêt avec que dalle, une sorte de man vs wild
improvisé. et ce qui est cool c'est que françois lui a des capacités particulières pour survivre en milieu hostile et naturel
c'est bien ça ? -Ouais c'est ça c'est un peu de ma passion c'est ce que j'aime faire dans la vie
-est ce que...  t'as été scout ou pas?
-alors pas du tout non. -On a atteint le milieu d'une forêt ok c'est pour ça qu'il y a cette très belle vue, on a marché pendant de
nombreuses heures pour ça, c'est faux je suis un gros mytho, bonjour
-On a marché une petite heure -Une petite heure? -Une petite heure -Eh c'est fou ça m'a épuisé
totalement on vient d'arriver je suis très content et on va pouvoir commencer à survivre en milieu hostile
Pour cette première étape nous devons trouver un endroit où construire notre habitat. Un endroit plat où on ne risque pas de rouler ou de chuter pendant
notre sommeil ce qui serait une chose terrible et on va construire au dessus de nous à l'aide de branches, de mousse, de feuilles un vrai
abri pour ne pas se prendre de la pluie dans la nuit parce qu'il pleut en fait aujourd'hui
pendant que je parle je gagne du temps car mes collègues sont en train de faire le boulot et je ne les aide pas
ne partez jamais avec moi en pleine nature ! Regardez les ils travaillent. Ah bah parfait! Bah la première étape a été faite finalement
sans mon aide  On va mettre un petit trépied qu'on va construire et...
-Non mais
on dirait c'est simple
Bon là on va construire un petit trépied, ensuite on va installer l'électricité au niveau de cet arbre juste là. -On test, alors,  on s'allonge les gars
Lucas tu as une place préféré? Tu dors à gauche ou a droite dans ton lit généralement?
-Tu préfères cette mauvaise herbe ou cette
brindille? -Ok vous êtes bien? -Je veux juste proposer une technique parce que j'ai pas trop envie de me salir ça vous dérange pas?
je suis archi bien -Donc voilà on sera allongé tous les trois comme ça donc on met le trépied derrière nous... ok
Merci Lucas -ça me tend pardon . Cette place est assez confort donc je suis content. Il est l'heure de la deuxième étape
-Là il faut qu'on prévoit un trépied pour accrocher la poutre qu'on va coucher d'un côté sur un arbre de l'autre côté sur le trépied
on ramène on rapatrie les sacs pour établir le camp de base ici. -Excellent
On est bien tout seul.
FRANCOIS!!!
Bon bah je peux pas l'aider. Ah! C'est partit on va l'aider.
-Pardon excuse moi. -Je t'en prie -On va le tirer en mode celui-là il va venir vers moi
C'est un échec
l'une des trois branches a cédé sous le poids elle était un peu trop morte voilà c'est pour ça qu'il faut trouver des branches qui
sont pas mortes sinon elles sont trop fragilisées elles se pètent c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut arracher des branches des arbres
attention on n'utiliser que du bois qui est déjà au sol. Allez deuxième essai c'est parti !
Tu veux de l'aide peut-être, parce que je m'amuse mais je vois que t'es en souffrance -Bah ce que tu peux refaire comme tout à l'heure c'est à dire je vais le
lever et tu vas passer là et tu vas me passer la corde - Avec plaisir, par contre tu arrêtes de balancer  la corde dans la tête ça fait deux fois! Ah j'en peux plus
Incroyable -Voilà -Et on a un trépied -Et on a un trépied -Alors on peut toujours pas faire de
podcasts dans notre chambre malheureusement mais on peut dormir en forêt
il est fatigué
Blague à part il faut finir l'étape 2 en gros on a créé un support du coup on a une branche qui tient à
l'horizontale à 1
mètre 80 du sol
et maintenant il va falloir fouttre les branches qu'il y-a ici le long de celle qui à l'horizontale et ensuite recouvrir le tout
de feuilles, de brindilles, d'êtres, de cadavres, de plein de choses diverses et variées, pour nous protéger des intempéries
Tatata, je suis dans l'abri actuellement et franchement good job parce que il est propre hein les mecs, il est bien isolé
on a une petite odeur naturelle de verdure je sens qu'on va bien dormir, ça c'est sûr
on a une pierre à feu ok à laquelle on va frotter un allume feu, qu'on a trouvé dans la forêt on a vraiment eu beaucoup de chance
on est obligé d'avoir un minimum de matos avec nous quoi, cela n'empêche la difficulté ça va être de trouver du bois qui peut
s'embraser donc du bois sec et là il a plu de ouf
donc tout est parfaitement humide donc en gros on est obligé de choper du bois épais
pour le couper et chopper l'intérieur qui lui est sec
Pour avoir des bûches toute la soirée moi mon travail ça va être de faire exactement comme je viens de
faire là un mini abri pour pouvoir suspendre les bus à ça au dessus du feu et pour pouvoir avoir du bois sec à volonté
Il va falloir travailler on va faire ça vous et moi, allez c'est partit
Et de 1.
Ok on a nos 3 bouts de bois
Oh putain eh ça marche bien tu vois
putain je suis fier de moi c'est comme si j'avais un enfant
c'est parti bien sûr pour refaire un trépied d'une qualité extrême qui va impressionner François
Moment de vérité je relève le deuxième trépied. Ai-je réussi ma mission jusqu'au bout?
est ce que François ce soir sera fier de moi?
mais normalement j'ai fait ce qu'il faut
tu vois
normalement puisque en fait j'ai joué à the forest bah du coup ça tient
T'es content François? -Nickel
-ça va tomber -Qu'est ce qui va tomber? -Celui-là -Mais il n'y a rien qui va tomber.
du coup là on va pouvoir poser les choses ici au dessus du feu pour que ça sèche
j'ai réussi ma mission, François a quasiment terminé de préparer le bois pour le feu et Florian a terminé l'isolation
-C'est un putain de beau travail d'équipe -Yeah, yeah
Mec on est tellement des gros nolife qu'on a réussi à construire
l'abri au seul mètre carré où il y'a de la 3g de toute la forêt
Génial. Ils arrivent on va voir leurs réaction.
-Bon, t'es bien ou pas là? -J'suis super bien
Les amis la nuit est en train de tomber et nous allons enfin allumer ce fichu feu qui est l'étape la plus stressante
pourquoi ? parce que si on n'arrive pas à l'allumer, on mange pas ce soir
ici on a vraiment de quoi faire sécher des bûches on a plein de bois vous avez fait un taffe monstrueux
rien ne pourrait être plus satisfaisant que de réussir à allumer le feu. Est-ce que vous êtes prêts les gars? -allez vas-y
Putain c'est stressant les gars
Les gars, les gars, les gars ça va prendre
allez allume toi, allume toi bébé. Les gars j'ai fais le premier feu de ma vie. Enfin je veux dire sans
briquet quoi ni allumettes. C'est pas mal ce qui se passe -c'est pas mal ouais. -Ce feu va devenir adulte
C'est officiel le feu est devenu adolescent et il sera bientôt adulte
Le moment est venu de découvrir cette fameuse côte de bœuf. Elle est belle
On va découper des petit bout je pense
le morceau est tellement énorme. Il a vraiment dit au boucher je veux l'animal entier s'il vous plaît
elle est en place, les gars on se rapproche du but vous vous rendez compte de ce qui se passe
Ils s'en foutent. Attends c'est quoi que t'as, je peux voir?
attends, vous avez une cuitochette c'est incroyable
il est temps d'inaugurer le bal, puis-je avoir la cuitochette ?
c'est parti
Parfait et la viande est archi bonne ça se voit que t'as été chez un boucher, un vrai boucher quoi
-J'ai un truc pour toi Lucas, attends bouge pas
Pas trop, pas trop, c'est fort
Ok
Les amis nous venons de terminer notre repas actuellement il fait très nuit et on a la chance d'être dans une forêt
Bref j'ai proposé à Florian de profiter de ce décor incroyable. Finalement vous allez venir en colonie avec nous C'est partit -Petite exploration nocturne
Ok on vient de trouver une petite cavité mec si tu te fait attraper par un monstre je cours
Oh mais mec, mais mec !
Pourquoi on s'est pas mis là ? C'est vraiment une caverne
C'est génial c'est vraiment quand on a établi notre campement et tout qu'on trouve un endroit beaucoup mieux
après peut-être moins fun c'est que ça appartient à un ours on sait pas
elle est vraiment parfaite on dirait qu'elle a été taillée par un mec quoi. Bon bah c'est la petite découverte du soir qui nous met bien on est content
regardez comme françois est un homme bon on rentre au campement et là surprise
les sacs de couchage sont prêts sous la cabane ! Bonjour je dors aujourd'hui pour la première fois de ma vie entre deux hommes
les mecs merci pour cette journée c'était cool. merci à toi Lucas.
demain réveil à quelle heure ? à 7 heure très bien allez bonne nuit à tous
ça va faire extrêmement mal au revoir
Bonjour nous venons de nous réveiller il faudra redescendre vous êtes montagne pour aller prendre un train
ça caille tellement est ce vrai ouais ça caille oui
ce qu'il faut savoir qu'on est en slip dans les sacs de couchage et qu'il faut qu'on sorte du sac de couchage
Les amis il faut vous dire que c'est officiellement la fin de cette vidéo
yes et qu'on va rentrer chez nous au chaud les mecs c'était une putain d'expérience c'était vraiment génial
1000 mercis attend j'suis à 8 mètres de vous c'est génial on dirait qu'on est pas du tout amis ! (rires)
C'était assez ouf j'avais pas fais ça depuis des années enfin j'avais pas fait ça tout court solo sans animateur de colonie
la dernière fois que je l'ai fait j'avais 12 ans c'est vrai que c'est assez épanouissant quoi être comme ça en pleine nature
un peu déconnecté mais pas trop non plus qu'il faut lancer une ou deux games d'hearth stone pour sentir bien
construire des trucs c'était très cool
voir qu'avec en fait juste des bouts de bois et de la ficelle tu peux tu peux
te choper un petit abri enfin c'est vraiment marrant en plus c'était vachement cool d'être tous les 3 ouais
ouais exactement il y a un mood entre potes qui est vraiment cool c'est tellement sympa très sympa
même si non mais j'ai hyper bien dormi même si mamytwink a pété cette nuit
il faut savoir il a lâché 1 pet de ouf ça sentait très mauvais dans l'abri alors qu'on est en plein air
Sans déconner vous savez que j'adore le prout et bah il m'a gâté hein, il m'a vraiment mis bien ! mille merci pour cette expérience
bim high five!
puis on se retrouve je suis pas trop non plus mais on se retrouve bientôt pour les potes dans la grotte
à bientôt les amis n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo si elle vous a plu à les voir la chaîne Mamytwink très important et la chaîne de François
et je vous fais un maximum de bisous et à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo dans mon studio
Voilà est-ce que c'est une bonne phrase de fin ? Je suis pas sûr je suis pas convaincu !